so guys if you were not in a social club
right now the fact that you can trade
cards is absolutely one of the biggest
benefits to being in a social club
because in this game you want duplicates
of cards you especially cards that you
actually like cards that you use a lot
you want a lot of duplicates and maybe
you're having a certain card that you're
just really having a hard time getting
this interface right here the trade card
interface is only accessible
through your social club so here I am in
my social club Hub house rack and tour
represent and if I go over here to this
board here you can see that it says card
trade so I click on that right here and
then this is the interface so this is
where I can request a card so I can look
through any of these cards here and I
could request them now in order to do so
like let's say that I want a legendary
because there's still a couple
legendaries that I don't have yet I do
not have this one for example do not
have fiend fire right here so let's say
I wanted fiend fire I wouldn't be able
to do it because I do not have a
legendary token this token right here
legendary tray token obtained via Club
adventure and can be used to trade one
legendary card during the Social Clubs
card trade event now if I could though
if I did have one of these tokens then
in this area right here I could fill
this up with all the cards that I would
be willing to trade for fiend fire right
here so I'm gonna back up and we're
gonna do it with a common card something
that I have a lot of and it'll make lot
more sense so like here's a inflatist
right here so I love using inflatus so
let's say I want another copy of
inflatus because right now mine is only
at level seven so I want to get a bunch
of copies of this card so I can upgrade
it even more
so I put that right here now here I can
say trade with any card so we got what
six slots right here so I could say you
know what I'll trade one of these I'll
trade one of these I'll trade one of
these I'll trade one of these looks like
I have nine of them things that either I
don't use a lot or things that I just
have a lot of now you don't even have to
fill it all the way up like I don't have
to go all the way to six here and then
let's do these right here so now if I
hit exchange cards it's going to use up
one of these tokens right here so I have
four rare trade tokens
and then the person who initiates the
trade with me they would also have to
spend a token so I'm gonna go ahead and
hit exchange cards
and we'll hit that right there and so
then it's going to show up in this list
right here so this list is all of these
Social Club requests right now so it's
not just mine other people in our social
club so you see right here house is
requesting this monster book card right
here and then he's offering up these two
cards so you don't even have to fill it
all the way up now I actually have let's
see I don't think I'm I'm ready to trade
this because looks like I only have two
right here
that's a card that I really haven't had
a lot of chance to experiment with yet
this one I don't have any extras at all
of so I couldn't even trade that one if
I wanted to same thing for right here
yeah so I don't think I have any that I
could trade with somebody now you see
right here this is one of my legendaries
that I'm requesting and then this will
remain valid for six days so a full week
that this will stay up and if I hit
trade records right here you'll actually
be able to see all of the completed
traits that I have made as a result of
doing this a couple of cards I have
gotten only because others have been
willing to trade with me right here
confringo for example I only got via
trade that was my first time ever
getting that card so this is absolutely
a huge huge benefit to being in a social
club try it out if you're not in a
social club yet head on over to our
Discord there's a link in the
description below we have a magic awaken
Channel there and we are in the process
of making multiple Social Clubs now if
you're just starting out with the game
there are some major things that you
definitely need to know some mistakes
that you do not want to make and I've
already made a video on those I've got
it ready for you right now on the right
side of your screen as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon